con ý Vy,
vw
Bây giờ em nghĩa một
Hoc em chữ.
Hoc em chữ göster.
Cái gì chung lối h focus.
Họ, mình có thể chung lối đây.
Đúng không?
Cái gì chung lối h movimento?
Họ không?
Thôi lúc đó, puede ngó.
Họ để bà tâm.
Hụi những gặn đánh bây giờ em có dấu nhật.
Nó quá meer, người cũng không phải gặp.
Nó, người sẽ mất ngấp dẫn.
B conect bẩn ph 재, đừng港 vstorm
N têm cây mà một sinh ra trái b혼
Rồi brother bán gì uống
Cepend ta đã bảo v menjadi chuyện complete
M Tat Thuyền k year
Mà gư
Vào luy
inaire
Mà gư Speaking ofagers
Con tiger
Con rę si brain
Con 올라Qi thì mà tiền
Anh không biết risk
Anh không biết con 꽃
Con constitu cũng có mua
Con achterer
Con yộc
Honey?
型
D curves
Ông vị
yên
Đ Mirean
Ừ
Tôi
Qoon
Cho
Th vors